tangorre citron mandarine des agrumes
sur tous les étals pendant toute une
journée
la commune de la petite île a fêté son
fruit charismatique du producteur au
consommateur la fête des agrumes c'est
l'occasion de faire le plein de
vitamines et de faire des économies
malheureusement à cause d'une saison des
pluies qui s'est prolongé la production
d'agrumes cette année est en net recul
la cub a été pendant de très nombreuses
années à fleuron de la diversification
toutefois nous avons des vergers
vieillissants aujourd'hui et il nous
faut préparer l'avenir renouveler les
souches et c'est ce à quoi on encourager
agrumiculture cette année puisque nous
avons constaté une baisse importante de
la production et on est là pour les
encourager et on montre que la
municipalité du département nous sommes
aux côtés des agriculteurs pour les
aider à se relancer dans cette culture
la culture des agrumes des tangos des
mandarines des citrons des pamplemousses
tout cela ces petites îles et c'est la
richesse de notre terroir relancer cette
activité emblématique de la commune de
la petite île c'est la volonté affichée
par le conseiller général en charge de
l'agriculture cinq vendeurs d'agrumes
étaient présents lors de cette
manifestation et tout s'accorde à dire
que le climat a causé énormément de
dégâts dans les champs
cette année il ya des fleurs qui ne sont
pas dues au début voilà
et avec beaucoup de pluie
mouloud en lieux
l'attitude 1 900 mètres dont plus de
difficultés cette année c'était pour moi
pour l'instant c'est par une très très
bonne année vu le climat super titi elle
début du mois de janvier
la pluie tombe beaucoup diraient du
graining peut-être une fois par semaine
il ya eu du beau temps aidant tout
l'ensemble baigne et ce n'est pas parce
qu'une bonne campagne quand même niveau
du tendon au nom de l'avenir écoles ce
qui reste parce que la maca est traité
de la terre battue
une manifestation qui s'est déroulée en
même temps que l'opération l'escale au
pays du terroir il s'agit tous les
deuxièmes samedis du mois de valoriser
la production agricole de petite-île un
18 juin qui a aussi été l'occasion de
remettre les prix du concours maisons et
jardins fleuris
nous avons reçu donc premier prix pour
notre jardin je suis très content mais
je voudrais quand même dire que d'abord
c'est un geste citoyen d'avoir un beau
jardin pour une commune comme petite île
c'était aussi une manière pour mieux
d'embellir notre notre commune
d'attirer maximum de gens avoir un cadre
de vie sympathique et pour nous et pour
tout le monde à la réunion tout le monde
aime son petit coin de jardin son jardin
créole
même s'il est un peu enfouis russie les
ranger un petit peu par espèce mais je
crois que le jardin fait partie de notre
savoir vivre de notre savoir faire
aujourd'hui je pense que partager tout
ça avec le grand public c'est une
magnifique choses et la réunion je pense
que c'est une île fleury c'est une
vitrine de la biodiversité réunionnaise
ils sont au total une centaine de
producteurs à cultiver des agrumes sur
la petite île une année difficile mais
les pouvoirs publics comptent bien
mettre les moyens pour que la petite
ville redevienne la capitale des agrumes
de la réunion